let's talk about psychological
operations my friends we got this story
from the financial times
psyops are a crucial weapon in the war
against disinformation well this is
clearly fake news because mass formation
psychosis isn't real oh yeah it's not
it's not real that ap told me so reuters
said it's not real for those that watch
joe rogan's podcast you need not hear me
explain this but for those that missed
it dr robert malone brought up how in
you know the early 1900s or you know 30s
people were trying to understand how it
is that these authoritarian regimes took
power namely nazi germany and he
mentioned something called mass
formation psychosis where people were
all basically fixated on something they
were hypnotized all of a sudden the
media comes out claiming it's not true
google changes the search results so
you're not finding it and now
it's it's funny because you had many
many stories over the past several years
from mainstream and corporate
publications saying that trump was
hypnotizing people
but when when you know even from the ap
the ap said that from the ap
and so now you have for the financial
times psychological operations are a
crucial weapon in the war against
disinformation but far be it from any uh
from from us to claim that there's
manipulation and hypnosis and propaganda
you know what the craziest thing to me
is when i would explain to people uh
there's a field of the of hacking
agriculture called social engineering
the overwhelming majority of hacking
that you hear in the news is actually
just social engineering someone's not
typing away code and there's like you
know smiling laughing faces appearing on
the screen eating the numbers like
ridiculous graphics hacking is almost
always some guy picking up a phone
calling the the bank and being like hi
i'm john i'm a branch manager it's you
know at bank number 3942 i'm looking for
your irs you know a verification number
and just tricking people that's what
hacking tends to be
this when i try to explain to people
this they always just say oh that would
never work on me
never work if it wouldn't then why does
it exist if you can't be manipulated why
does coke spend so much money buying
advertisements so when they come out and
say mass formation psychosis of course
it's a real thing
of course people are trying to
manipulate you every day now the
financial times is advocating for
psychological operations over coveted
misinformation which brings me to what
we have to deal with the censorship
which is a prime component of this
making sure people can't share ideas
sometimes the ideas are so dangerous
they'll shut off a live stream
mid-stream they'll ban a channel
outright with no strikes because the
information can't be allowed well
sometimes it's not even that they're
dangerous it's just that they're
misinterpreted which is a problem that
there's a human that's capable of
misinterpreting a message and then
banning it but this is different this is
army psychological operations literally
using the power of information denying
information lying about information
making up information in order to have
political games this is psychological
warfare against the american people that
the financial times is calling to be
instituted here in the united states and
they use sweden as the perfect example
because in sweden they have the swedish
psychological defense agency that
couldn't be more of an orbital name than
it could be but they are out there not
only to monitor what's happening online
not just the political discussions but
they also are there to launch
counter-attacks against their believed
falsehoods about vaccines immigration
and other very important issues so they
also talked about in this article how
they they use this psychological
operation to deal with political
tensions in europe so so this is an
important distinction to understand here
financial times is saying sweden's doing
this we need to do this here we already
do this here in the united states a lot
of this is classified and i think a lot
of this is very evident when you see the
same kind of regurgitated talking points
the same kind of narrative and anything
questioning getting outright censored
and banned there's also of course people
planting fake stories and fake
disinformation in order to throw people
off the original trail there's a lot of
things happening here and i think once
you institute psychological tricks by
the us army to to push an agenda that
only clearly benefit the billionaire
class the billionaires are making more
money than ever this is something that
is absolutely concerning this is
something that is absolutely worrying
and this is something that we need to
realize is happening here in the united
states on a huge level already this is
what we see with the banning of the
hunter biden laptop story on twitter and
facebook and so uh sitting before us we
got uh we got two people well well we
got the ceo of rumble and you guys are
is it fair to say your anti-censorship
on rumble absolutely um we're
what you're what you're seeing right now
but you got it you have to explain that
anti-censorship yeah you ban content
don't you well absolutely yeah we do and
uh we have policies that have been in
place since 2013 um and we haven't
really we haven't moved the goal post
since that time um obviously
you know terrorist organizations
promoting terrorist organizations
incitement to violence child pornography
pornography all that stuff's not
acceptable on the platform
and uh but what's what we're seeing here
right now and kind of why you've seen
companies like rumble grow is
not because of the terms and conditions
that we put together in 2013 that really
has no effect on on what what has
happened
um what you're seeing is that these
companies these
whether it's google or whether it's
twitter are now becoming arbiters of
truth they're they're being asked or
they're being forced or they're being
demanded by whether it's journalists or
governments to
basically determine
what's
what's good and what's not good imagine
me
how irresponsible would it be for me to
be the person that's going to tell you
what you can or cannot say
i went to university i dropped out in
third year and you want me to be that
person that's that's irresponsible you
want this the the ceo of youtube to be
that person that determines what is
right and what is wrong well they're
scared of losing advertisers i think is
a big component i do think that there is
absolutely a national defense component
we've heard tons of stories about you
know uh federal agencies going to tech
firms and saying
you have to do what we tell you and if
you tell anyone we told you to do this
we will destroy you yeah gag orders yeah
someone asked me to kind of ask you will
rumber rumble volunteer information
about its users to regulators in law
enforcement or will you guys demand a
warrant that's one of the questions that
someone it was was really interested if
you could answer
yeah we're not going to just hand over
information we're you know it's got to
go through the proper channels it has to
be legally done and
if you know there's a subpoena we'll
we'll follow the law in in all cases we
have to follow the law that's that's our
that's our duty it minds we have a weird
position well interesting it was a if
it's legal in the united states then
it's legal fine on minds it's part of
the terms and that meant like state law
like what state were we incorporated in
i think the time was connecticut so it's
connecticut state law but then you'd get
these things like lolliporn which is
like cartoon porn and the people look
young and they look under 18 but it's
cartoons so there's no human there's no
it's not illegal but it's devastating to
smear a website with that stuff so
you're like well
we have to do something about this and
so there's this clause you can ban
anything at any time i mean pretty much
any network can ban anybody at any time
yeah when you when we started websites
like 20 years ago like that's like a
standard term that every lawyer will put
in so it makes things easy and you know
that that's one of the problems right is
that when we started rumble we we have
these sets of terms and conditions that
were just so standard on the internet
everybody had pretty much the same terms
and conditions but
you know that's where everybody wants us
to have that conversation they want us
to have the conversation around the
really fringy stuff and all that stuff
but that's not what's happening here
that's not why companies like rumble are
growing rumble is growing because
something
more overt and egregious is happening
and that's because you can't even have a
conversation that you have at your
dinner table anymore um an open
conversation on on the internet think
about this think about what we're doing
right now on youtube we we can't have an
open conversation here there's a lot of
things we cannot talk about that if
these mics are off you could talk about
that we will at timecast.com in the
members only segment
and that's the craziest thing that we
have to do that
and interestingly on itunes and
spotify's other platforms
they're actually much more lacked
spotify is actually fairly strict uh
because they've got internal people who
will ban you and there's no appeal
process worse than youtube but uh itunes
just goes hey look we don't host any of
the content we're just linking to it
yeah i think that's google podcast's
position as well i believe and if
someone violates the law this the state
should get involved here not of course
the arbiters of truths a middle person
that's going to say well this idea is
bad for you that that whole concept is
is patronizing and it's very
disrespectful to anyone paying attention
in my opinion there's like uh situations
where the law is bad and you want to
you know not not necessarily well look
nazi germany for instance well we're
just talking about like death threats
and the free speech laws that we have on
the books if for instance a law got
passed that was so insidious and we're
like well we have to violate that law
because that's corrupt we can't
absolutely that it's hard to to make a
social network the one that's like we're
going to uphold that and let people do
when we're going to let people violate
the law because then it's easy to find
out where they live you know who owns
that site you know where that data is
hosted i i'm very nervous about
centralization of authority um
holding data on a centralized network of
any kind whether it's email addresses um
search history because the nsa can just
go take it well let me let me ask the
more data the worse right you guys
yeah maybe there's a diminishing return
on that but yeah thanks for checking out
this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast if you want to watch live you
can check out this channel monday
through friday at 8pm
and don't forget to smash that like
button subscribe to this channel and if
you want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time
you